welcome everybody uh last talk of the
afternoon is mina karzan from
university of california there is she
will be talking about representation
cost of linear neural networks analysis
and design
thank you
um so this is joint work with uh zhen
dai who's a a phd student at the math
applied math department at uchicago and
national at ttic
so um the classic problem of supervised
learning is that given a training set of
with n samples you want to learn a
function in some function class such
that f of x is a good predictor of the
labels y
and we're going to focus on
parameterized mappings such that these
functions are from inputs
and are described or determined by these
parameter p dimensional parameters w and
uh f of x and w is
the learner's prediction about the label
and we try to have it as close as
possible to why so the learning
algorithm would be
learning the parameters w given the
training set based on you know the
training set and usually we use some
form of optimization algorithm to do
that
most of the talk will be about neural
networks in which these parameterized
functions are associated with some
architecture um in which their
activation functions and you know the
input goes through layers and each in
each layer there is a weight matrix that
mixes things and then there's an
activation function typical choices of
activation function are
relu sigmoid identity functions and
in this talk we're going to focus on
linear neural networks so the activation
functions are just going to be identity
functions
so basically your function is just going
to be multiplication of various matrices
times the input
so typically in applications neural
networks operate in over-parameterized
regimes um which you could just define
differently you could say that the
number of parameters is larger than the
number of
samples that you have or the capacity of
the class of functions is much larger
than what you need to describe the data
or to fit the data
but now the question is uh one of the
questions is that given a sample set and
an over characterized class of functions
there could exist many functions in this
class of functions that fit the data
perfectly and now the question is which
one generalizes well which one should we
pick
um this is a classic example in which
you have 11 points and then if you fit
fit it using a linear function then you
cannot fit all the data
uh but if you use a polynomial of degree
10 then you fit it perfectly but you
probably over fit so it doesn't
generalize now if you try to
use a polynomial of degree 17 for
example there are many many curves that
fit the data perfectly and you have a
choice to you know which one you're
going to pick
um
in the past recent uh past few years
there's been a few uh interesting
observations empirical observations
we've seen this many times so far
that in practice when we increase the
capacity of our function class
obviously the training error goes down
and eventually actually it reaches zero
so we have zero training loss but the
tester goes down and actually doesn't
come up or comes up and then again goes
down so this is the surprising part that
even though we have zero training error
um and we're interpolating still the the
the model generalizes
um
similar curves have been seen before i'm
going to talk a little bit about
double decent curve paper by misha
that similar curves have been seen in
other setups that again the training
error reaches zero and the tester keeps
on going down and
this promoted this idea of double decent
care that
the
the training loss is going to go down as
the capacity of your class of functions
increases
but the tester
goes up goes down and up this is the u
curve which is classic machine learning
uh
underfitting overfitting but then after
these interpolation thresholds during
the over parameterized regime in this
regime there are many functions that can
interpolate the data and with the proper
choice of you know this interpolating
function
maybe we can
we can have you know risk going down in
our parameterized regime
so in a nutshell uh it seems that the
capacity of the function class does not
reflect the generalization property we
should look into something else
and it seems that
in this over parameterized regime
irregularity or smoothness of the
functions um are somehow measured by
some form of function norm and that's
what determines the generalization
properties and we're going to talk a lot
about this notion of regularity or
smoothness
um
and
in addition it seems that by increasing
the capacity of h we're just looking at
the larger class of functions and we are
able to find uh interpolating functions
that have actually smaller norms so
they're actually smoother so we're
hoping that you know that that's that's
the you know by finding smoother
functions the generalization is going to
get better
so again this is one of the classic
examples in which you have 10 data
points and if you use a two-layer uh
relu network with uh 40 hidden nodes you
get you can interpolate but the function
that the curve that you get is not
necessarily smooth but with four
thousand uh hidden nodes um you get a
much smoother uh function
and uh other uh
experiments show that actually uh
there's this notion of norm norm of the
weights that actually after you enter
the interpolative regime the the norm of
the weights go down at the same time as
the generalization you know improves
so it seems that the keyboard is minimum
normal interpolation that you're not
just interpolating you're trying to find
this smoothest interpolator possible
corresponding to some notion of minimum
note so there's a relationship between
um minimum norm smoothness
regularization
and uh you know that we all hope that
all of these will help us with the
generalization
so uh
just to put it in um in some notation uh
what we're trying to find is uh looking
at the class of functions f we're gonna
look at all the functions g such that
they interpolate so they fit the data
perfectly but among all these functions
that interpolate we're going to
find the argument of some cost over g
so there is this notion of cost of
representation cost of g
and we're going to find you know the
output of the learning algorithm is
going to be the minimum representation
cost of g
such that g interpolates
um
now we're going to talk a little bit
about what should be the this uh
loss function or the cost function
um and uh
there has been a lot of work recently
about that in the field um
i'm not gonna review all of them but the
basic idea is that there is this
marriage between optimization algorithms
and
um and the learning or the
generalization but basically our choice
of optimization algorithms are helping
us go toward finding these interpolators
that have a
minimum l2 norm of the parameter so in
the case of uh parameterized mappings
especially neural networks we're seeing
all these examples in which both
theoretically and in empirical results
the l2 norm of the weights is penalized
and that's uh that's what we're seeing
as the output of the algorithm
um
motivated by all this uh conversation
about the implicit regularization
um by the way this is one of the results
that i talked about that gradient
descent and homogeneous models um
implicitly regularize the l2 norm of the
parameters and even if we don't think
about the implicit regularization
there's this idea of explicit
regularization which in practice we do
weight decay a lot of the times that we
try to minimize the training loss but
also we try to you know minimize you
know use the weight decay and uh
motivated by both of these uh we're
gonna look into this minimum norm intel
interpolators such that uh you know if
my function is a parametric parametric
function so uh i just want to emphasize
on the notation here a little bit this f
of x and w it was the
um
parametric function um from input x and
parameters w to output y so this capital
f of w now is a function from x to y and
the output of the learning algorithm is
trying to find these weights such that
i want to find w such that f of w on x i
is going to be y i for all i but at the
same time i want to minimize the l2 norm
of w's
so
this is the representation of what the
algorithm seems to be doing in the
parameter space but we can write the
same thing in the function space
that now my output the learn the learned
model f
is going to be argument of this cost
function over g such that g's are in
these functions in the function class
and they interpolate well but now i have
to define this representation cost of g
this is the formulation that we wanted
to get into and the representation cost
of a specific function g
is actually the minimum norm of minimum
l2 squared norm of ws such that f of w
is equal to g again i want to emphasize
that f of w and g are both functions
from x to y
so there are two minimizations here
among all the functions in f that
interpolate i'm going to look at all the
functions that that in f that
interpolate and for each g i'm going to
look into all weights or all the
parameters that represent g
remember that my parametric
representation might be redundant there
might be many many different
realizations of the weights that give me
the same function so i'm going to look
at all these bits and look at which one
gives me the minimum l2 squared norm and
that would be the representation cost of
g
and now the output of the learning
algorithm is going to be the g that
interpolates and also has the minimum
representation cost
and uh even if you don't have exactly
like minimum
interpolation and we have some form of
regularization we can have the similar
formulation that
maybe we want to have the
minimize the empirical loss of some
learner with parameters w
and penalize l2 norm of w and this is
exactly the same as you know the same
minimization but in the function space
and now that i find i want to find a
function
g in the you know calligraphic f or the
image of this parametrization f
such that the minimum cost
representation the minimum cost
representation of g is minimized
or sorry this is you're not it is used
as a penalty so the goal of this talk is
understanding the relationship between
these formulations understanding how
minimizing the
uh or penalizing l2 normal parameters
affects the penalization or
regularization of the in the function
states
and in practice and in particular i want
to emphasize that we don't actually
really care about the
um representation minimum cost
representation or the representation
cost which what we care about is the
representation cost up to some
equivalence where the equivalence is
defined by you know you can define it as
um the ordering that it induces over the
functions in your function class so if
two
representation costs induce the same
ordering over all functions in my
function class they're equivalent
because the output of this algorithm is
going to be the same for these two
representations or one is the monotonic
function of the other
so these are two examples in which you
know if you have for example two
networks for one of them representation
cost of uh g is equal to representation
cost of g and the other one to the power
of two for all g's
then uh these two net for the output of
these two networks will be always they
will always be the same according to
this formulation
um
and the other one is that we say that
the neural network induces l1 norm as
its complexity measure if the
representation cost is monotonic to l1
so all i want to say is that
representation cost
is only important up to this equivalence
of phenomena functions and that's what
we call the induced induced complexity
measure in the function space that this
is the measure of complexity when we say
that in over parameterized regime we
want to find the least complex function
that interpolates it means that we want
to find this is the measure of
complexity that we that we're using
basically
and that's the that's the thing that
determines generalization properties of
the networks because that's the thing
that determines what is the output of
that word
now um what is the talk about the talk
is about understanding the relationship
between induced complexity measure and
the architectures of the uh deep network
or the neural network in particular we
have two questions in mind one is
analysis one is its design that given
an architecture or specific properties
of the architecture what can we see
about what can we say about the
induced complexity measure
um
[Music]
and in particular if we assume that the
l2 norm of the parameters is penalized
what is the finalization in the function
space
in the design we look at the other way
that if
i as a user
know that for some reason my data
prefers some form of regularization in
function space how can i um
change my network or design my network
in a way that that that that's the
induced complexity measure that these
are regularization for example if i want
to construct a linear network such that
uh it penalizes lp norm of uh linear
coefficients how should i do that you
know what kind of network does that
um throughout the talk we're going to
talk about uh we're going to focus on
linear neural networks and in particular
so the uh the input output relationship
is just going to be like this so the
network just operates as a product of
some matrices
so first let's talk about the analysis
part
and uh the first network that we look
into is the linear fully connected
neural network
in which we have these d matrices uh i'm
assuming that i'm not losing rank
between input and output the number of
hidden nodes is large enough
so the relationship between input and
output is like that and i'm assuming
again that there is no weight sharing
these matrices are independent of each
other
and
given a specific linear function g is
equal to beta x where m is the
dimensionality of the output and n is
the dimensionality of the input the
minimum cost representation of this beta
is going to be
this formulation that i'm going to look
at all w such that product of w is equal
to beta
and the cost is a summation of robinus
normal w that's the l2 norm of you know
the parameter vector w if you just stack
them on top of each other
this has been seen before in the
previous paper that the representation
cost of this uh network is uh
has this formulations d times summation
of
sigma i to the power of 2 over d where
sigma i is the
singular values of matrix beta
the proof is kind of very intuitive so i
suggest you think about it for a minute
if i want to have this formulation
there's no reason that w i's shouldn't
align if they don't align i'm losing a
spectral power on the way between input
to output so as soon as they align they
can commute
so they're symmetry so there should be
some kind of equivalence
um
they should be equal to each other
obviously like um there's a lot of
details that i'm skipping here because
the sizes can be different and then i
have to think about you know the uh the
rank of beta and that's what matters and
so on but uh basically we're going to
see that you know the singular value the
composition of w's are going to be very
similar uh to uh singularity composition
sorry the singular values of ws are
going to have a relationship with the
singular values of beta but the
singular vectors just need to align
um
so the induced complexity measure is
going to be
2 over d chat and
across the norm of peta
and in particular when we're looking at
the single output case where m is equal
to one the induced complexity measure is
just the l2 norm of the vector beta
so again um
yeah
so the singular value is the
norm of the matrix the norm of the
vector
ah so it's not the true value
here is
so that's the result about fully
connected neural network as i said most
of this was known before and but this is
like the most heuristic thing that's why
i put it here
the next example is diagonal neural
networks um this is the figure
um
so
in in
in words basically you have these uh
vectors uh d minus one vectors that
determine the weights from layer one to
d minus one and then the last layer is a
fully connected layer
so the representation cost is again
defined as the you know minimum over
summation of robinus norms but now i
want this property to hold the last
layer times this diagonal matrices
should be equal to beta
um
again if you think about it the proof
you know it's it's it's not that
difficult again these diagonal matrices
are can commute so you know that helps a
lot but uh now the representation cost
of you know given matrix beta is going
to be
is going to have this form and in those
complexity measure is this group norm of
l um 2 over d and d norm i don't know if
i've ever mentioned but d is the depth
of the network
um and in the case of
single output for m is equal to one this
is the induced complexity measure is not
going to be l two over d norm of beta
where beta is vector
next we're gonna talk about
convolutional neural networks in the
case of full-width convolutional neural
networks
where uh you know the operation between
input to output is just a bunch of
convolutions at d minus one layers and
again the last layer is fully connected
again this result was seen before
um
you want to minimize uh
the l2 norm of w's
uh subject to you know reconstruction
the trick is very simple is using
discrete fourier transform on everything
basically as soon as you use discrete
fourier transform and the circle and
matrices they become diagonal and uh you
can just do something very similar to
what you did for the diagonal matrix
networks but this time it's a fourier
domain
so the representation cost is going to
look like this and the induced complex
the measure again is the group norm of l
two over d and do
two and uh under fourier and the fourier
representation of beta
um and in the case of single output it's
just going to be two over the l2 over d
of beta hat
um
but the problem is that in practice we
don't usually use a full weight
convolutional neural networks we use
restricted bit convolutional normal
function which you know just some edges
are removed and this corresponds to
having these uh vectors that have only
two non-zero elements and then you
construct the circular matrices from
them and just apply them
um
but now finding the representation cost
of
restricted with convolutional neural
networks is very surprisingly very
difficult i spent a lot of time thinking
about it and it's not clear even if it's
there's a closed form solution and we
have a bunch of results that we're going
to talk about it parallel to our work uh
some other people
including surya mina and elias
have a paper that
get very similar lemmas to our paper but
they use semi-definite programming
techniques
the results as i said are kind of
partial and just making some
observations the first result is that in
a
two-layer network if the filter bit is
equal to one
and we have single output
uh
the
the representation cost is going to be
l2 normal fourier domain
um if the
q is equal to n which means that you
have
full weight the representation cost is
going to be the induced complexity is
going to be l1 normal fourier domain and
in practice in in in
essentially for any general q the
induced complexity is going to be
between l1 and l2
so it's going to interpolate these two
things but it's not clear how exactly
that happens
make some additional exa
observations that you know clearly
the representation cost should be
decreasing in q
um and the reason is that as you
increase q uh you're basically adding
edges so the representation cost cannot
go off
but uh it is not strictly decreasing we
have an encounter example for that that
you know it shows that there are cases
in which this is not strictly decreasing
and in other results we show that if q
divides n
again n is the uh
n is the input dimension and q is the
filter bit then the representation cost
for q for you know with filter with q is
going to be upper bounded upper and
lower bounded by their representation
cost of uh
you know cnn with one filter tap
within a factor of one over square root
q
and another result says that uh
the representation cost of multi-channel
cnn does not depend on m the number of
channels the number of outputs we showed
it for q equals one and n and these
people showed it for generality
the other kind of analysis results that
we have is related to residual neural
networks in which you know basically you
have you start from a homogeneous neural
network can you skip some layers um so
we in the case of linear non-homo linear
non-homogeneous neural network we can
show it by
starting from a homogeneous network and
and then constructing these compact
networks and one to nk
such that each of them are basically
selecting a bunch of layers
and then there is net is going to be
summation of these compact networks
again finding the closed form solution
of representation cost of resonance is
very difficult but uh we showed that uh
if
we think about the
depth of these
component networks um such that you know
the first one is the
most shallow one and the last one is the
deepest one
then for uh the first equation this one
says that if your input is extremely
small if the linear coefficients are
very small then the representation cost
looks like the representation cost of
the the most shallow one
and if the linear coefficients are very
large
then the representation cost of resnet
is very similar to the representation
cost of the deepest network
there is a simple and kind of
interesting example
which looks at this network which is
just a summation of a
fully connected uh one layer network
plus a diagonal two layer network
and then we showed that you know the
representation cost of that is just
gonna have this form where r of beta i
is
a unique positive root of some equation
so this is a very like implicit form of
showing
uh
the representation cost but then we
could show it for different values of
beta i and as you see for a small value
of beta i it looks like l2 norm and for
a large value of beta i looks like l1
norm and for anything in between it
basically interpolates
so uh as you see this is the l1 norm is
the uh is the representation cost of the
diagonal network with one layer which is
the deeper component nail two norm is
the representation constant cost of um
fully connected one layer network which
is the most shadow one
so so now um thinking about the design
part given some common regularization
functions in the function space we want
to construct architectures that induce
these uh penalties in the function space
and we're going to focus again on linear
networks but um almost all results that
we have in this part is on
single output networks
um so the first and simplest and kind of
cleanest result is on lp norm that if
you care about
you know inducing lp norm as the uh
regularization the function space
then uh first of all this is only
possible using linear homogeneous
networks
if
two over p is a
natural number
um and also we saw that you know
diagonal network of depth two over p
actually induces this
so
the interesting part here is that if 2
over p is not a natural number no linear
homogeneous network
can induce this lp as the
regularization or the other penalization
you know representation cost in the
functionality
so uh this is uh
related to this notion of mixing that
that i find interesting
so mixing that is kind of simple so uh
for any subset of nodes s
you can find the first layer in which
you find a node that's connected to all
these
all these nodes in s
um and that's the mixing depth of s
let's let's look at another example just
to show so for these nodes in red the
mixing depth of these two nodes is
actually one two three that layer three
this is the first time that you see a
node that
connects these nodes from input to
output and all of them are connected to
that node but the mixing node of mixing
depth of the first three nodes is just
gonna be here right that's the first
time that they're mixed together
so this this has a lot of like
you know
interpretation about you know how the
network is treating different dimensions
and actually this result about lp norm
is just saying that the representation
cost is lp if and only if for all
subsets of you know n
the mixing depth is 2 over p
so you know that the
diagonal network satisfies this property
clearly the first time that you have the
mixing of any all the subsets is you
know the last lecture which is two word
p
but um
but there are there are networks that
are not exactly diagonal there's some
redundancy in the network and still they
satisfy this property
so
this is the exact formulation of you
know what we need in a network to show
that in lp is the
regularization
the next regularizer that we care about
is the lp group norm so for a
given partitioning of numbers from 1 to
n
pq is defined as that so just you know q
over each graph each group and an lp
over you know between the groups
and then we have results that show that
first of all this can be the induced
complexity measure only if 2 over p and
2 over q are
natural numbers again
and if p is less than q we show the
architectures that have this as their
regularization as a as a
complexity measure
but if p is greater than q
we only construct the the architecture
for this very specific case that two
over p is equal to two over q minus one
and for other cases uh we actually don't
know what architecture shows that
um
so when p is less than q and we care
about you know as i said lpq the
architecture that has this induced
complexity measure is the one in which
it's diagonal in the first d minus one
elements
but it's diagonal only for each group so
the nodes in blue are in one group and
the nodes in
red are in another group
and then
after the two layers from the input you
mix different groups with each other
so again
note that this is the case that p is
less than q
and you care about the
acute norm inside the group and
you know d1 is 2 over q
so that's how you're mixing you know the
groups with each other and so on so
again this kind of this has a very nice
representation in terms of the mixing
depths
for the other case that p is greater
than q um
the the representation is slightly
different uh for d1 minus so d1 is two
over p
for the the first d1 layers you just
have diagonal but the next layer
you have one node corresponding to each
element of cartesian product of the
groups
so you have one node that's connected to
one element from each group and so on
that's how you're mixing different
groups with each other
and as i said for the general case of p
greater than q the architecture is not
known
the last example that i'm going to talk
about is the k support norms uh which
are defined as follows this is like a
summation of l2 norms between different
um
subsets of you know one to n such that
support of each of these elements is an
i you know i is the subset of n
and uh the the the summation of all of
them construct beta
and we showed that k support norms are
actually achievable using linear neural
networks and for that we need a
two-layer network where each node is
connected to
one of the groups uh
to one of the one of the subsets of uh
site
so each node corresponds to one subset
of size k
um of the n input dimensions
so this is the uh you know the brief
summary of the results that i mentioned
uh
but uh we had we had some observations
about the limitations of homogeneous and
neural networks not only linear but
homogeneous on our networks for example
we showed that if we looked at a lp
quasi norm with overlapping between the
groups
not the groups do not partition you know
one-to-one but they have overlap
or if you look at elastic nets
which is linear a combination of l1 and
alpha-2 norms as the regularizations in
the function space
no homogeneous uh neural network can
achieve these as the
induced complexity measure but we showed
some non-homogeneous parameterizations
that actually can achieve these things
so there are certain cases in it is it
is also you know the general case is
interesting that what are the
regularizations that can be achieved
with the homogeneous parameterizations
and they're the ones that
cannot um
so overall one of some of the future
work that i find interesting and
important is um the most pressing one
might be the convolutional or not the
representation cost of convolution
convolutional neural networks with a
finite filter beat
the design component with multiple
output is actually um not known you know
there are not that many results that we
know about that
again non-linear activation function
and uh you know general description of
properties of architectures that help us
achieve this induced complexities is
also not known
um and using this framework in a
pipeline understanding the connection
between
you know this representation cost to the
generalization properties and so on is
also important
questions
the natural question is
you know this is assuming that you you
really minimize this cost right in
practice you run some algorithms etc
do you have any idea of that how that
changes the effective recognition that's
an important question yeah
any other questions
okay sorry guess everybody's tired
so
thanks again mina
[Applause]
that's it folks
thank you